police in Austin Texas have removed
dozens of Department SUVs from service
over carbon monoxide concerns six
officers since Friday showed symptoms of
carbon monoxide poisoning they were all
driving Ford Explorers we reported in
February that hundreds of drivers
claimed the popular SUV was making them
sick since our report the number of
complaints is nearly doubled dashcam
video from 2015 shows a California
police officer who had passed out behind
the wheel crashing into a tree Kris Van
Cleave is at the Austin Police
Department with a potential danger to
officers Chris good morning good morning
the Ford Explorer makes up 61 percent of
the fleet of cruisers for the Austin
Police Department that's more than 300
vehicles and now the agency finds itself
debating if it needs to park them all
I'm lucky to be alive I believe that and
I'm lucky I didn't kill somebody else
and their family that night sergeant
Zachary LaHood was the first Austin
police officer to report being sickened
by a parent carbon monoxide exposure in
his Ford Explorer police cruiser I don't
remember if I hit a curb or if my head
just hit the window and it woke me up
but I remember swerving to miss a
head-on collision that's when I realized
man I need to get help something is
wrong LaHood is still on medical leave
and is now suing Ford Austin police
installed these carbon monoxide
detectors in their Explorers after the
incident which APD says have gone off 37
times those SUVs have been pulled out of
service and in just the last week six
officers have been treated for carbon
monoxide exposure assistant chief troy
gay if the end result that we end up
parking several hundred utility vehicles
and that is ultimately the decision if
we continue to have occurrences then we
will do that since our February report
the number of complaints involving 2011
to 2017 model year Ford Explorers not
just police units nearly doubled to 771
federal regulators are now investigating
if the issue in Austin is related to a
potential safety defect Ford has known
about this
situation since at least 2012 a company
representative later acknowledged in a
deposition it appears to be a design
issue that may allow exhaust which
contains carbon monoxide to seep in
likely through unsealed seams in the
rear of the SUV Ford needs to step up to
the plate take responsibility and get
these cars off the road they need to
issue a recall there is no denying the
fact that these cars are going to kill
people Ford says its investigation found
no signs of a carbon monoxide issue in
the design of these police interceptor
explorers the company did say that some
departments do make modifications after
they get the vehicles and they're
working with departments to make some
fixes that could solve those issues so
the Austin Police Department tells us
they've had carbon monoxide issues with
vehicles where they made modifications
and ones that came straight from the
dealer Norah good to know Chris thank
you so much